so how many have this question like how
can you make teaching come alive and be
more engaging yep so you must have
thought about it sometime when you are
taking the course or when you are
delivering a course so this is a
question which is mostly asked and there
are a lot of solutions to this to this
and this solutions depend on the course
you are taking or add the number or the
student who is taking the course like
every student has a different way of
learning in this presentation I'll be
presenting to you one such tool which we
have developed to make teaching come
alive which is called Wolfram virtual
labs and this virtual the first the lab
which I will be going through today we
developed this along with Professor
Matthew from Politecnico di Torino in
Italy in this presentation I will talk
to you I will discuss what are this
virtual labs like why we created this
virtual labs and I will go through an
example of how this looked like and I
will present the resources where you can
go and learn more about it
yes so during the last few years are
doing a discussion with various teachers
professors and students like Professor
Yehuda who is sitting over here
professor mati oh and and these are the
professors we were asking them how can
we make use of system modular or
Mathematica and make education come
alive and during those discussions we
had several points and out of that three
points were kind of common all those
discussions the first was the prophecies
wanted some example which are just not a
code snippet like it's just not a
manipulate but they wanted a workflow so
that when you go through it you
understand what's happening so I will go
more into more into that when I present
the virtual lab the second thing was if
a if a professor is developing a course
using Mathematica and system modeler
they wanted a platform from where they
can share it with other teachers and
students and the last thing was they
wanted to create such materials which
can be easily implementable in the class
in the classroom so a teacher doesn't
need to take the pains to improve it or
to modify it as per the course
requirement so based on this three now
this three major background we did some
brainstorming and we thought okay how
can we make the complete use of the
Wolfram tech and the teachers
requirement and how can we develop
something new and before we started to
develop this virtual labs we decided to
focus on three key values like we will
develop some materials which make
teaching come alive which are adaptable
to any course and third we will develop
courses which will cover the whole
curriculum generally the perception
about system model errors it is used in
physics or in mechanics but it is not
the case it can be used over wide range
of courses and through this virtual labs
we want to present how it can be used in
different fields
to demonstrate that I will be going
through the first virtual lab for lab
library called college thermal which has
two virtual labs on room heating and on
refrigeration cycle you can download
this from the Wolfram modular from the
system modular library store so when you
download this when you download this
library traditionally when you download
a system Wadler library it is in the
form of an SMA but for this virtual labs
when you download this library you will
get a Mathematica notebook in this
notebook as you can see we begin by a
general introduction to this library and
then we present the two labs which we
are presenting in this library which is
room heating and refrigeration cycle
what each lab we give a brief
description of what the student will
learn at the end at the end of the lab
and then we present the final manipulate
which the student will be using in this
lab so that a student knows what he is
going to going to get after reading this
lab so so you get this library notebook
and whichever lab you like to try it out
you can just hit try the lab so when you
click try the lab the system order file
is automatically downloaded and
installed and everything happens
automatically in the background so as a
student or as a professor who is new to
Wolfram tech you don't need to know
anything about system Mahler or
Mathematica and how it how it works you
don't even need to know how to like you
don't even need to know shift-enter
to evaluate an expression it's we have
automated that to that level before I
proceed and explain one of the labs
let me tell you like what do I mean when
I say make hitting come alive so we have
approached this value through mainly
three points the first is we as you know
Alex seed to harvest so we start with
very simple models and we start calming
adding more complexity to that and at
the end we have a complete or a
non-trivial model second we when we
develop this when a student goes through
the slabs we present them various
manipulates through which they can
compare different scenarios third we use
our dynamic tools of math of Wolfram
tech to create this courses more
interesting now let me show you how this
lab looks like so this is one of the lab
of college thermal room heating lab we
start with a brief introduction of what
this lab is about for instance here we
give the big picture that at the end of
this lab you will be able to model the
internal temperature of a room for any
given in beam condition so a student
knows ok once I finish this lab what am
I going to learn and how can I use it in
real life so we first start with giving
a top level view of that then we give
some objectives which are relevant to
the course he is taking and this is
based on the teachers feedback like all
these labs we develop in collaboration
with professors and teachers
so this objectives we get from the
professor's and once you know what are
the objectives you are going to cover we
start by modeling
simple components for instance in a room
model the wall is the simplest component
so we first model the wall then we go on
and add more complexity and at the end
we combine everything and create the
room model let's in this presentation
let me show you what we do in exercise 1
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just
to make it clear yeah just to make it
clear you don't the student don't need
to develop this models this models have
been developed the mathematical models
and the system Warner models have been
developed and are readily available for
use so a student doesn't need to make
this models they will only use this
models to know more about the system
right so in this wall model what we can
see here are three thermal conductor
layers and this our insulation brick and
insulation layers and we had we are
giving two boundary condition which is
the ambient temperature and at the end
the inside room temperature so this is
the first simple model we start with
with a very simple model of a wall once
a student is introduced with this model
then we give a brief description that
what are the parameters which are
important in this model for instance in
this model thermal conductivity and
thickness of the wall is more important
then we present a manipulate where we
keep the thickness as constant here the
thickness of the brick layer which is
thins the brick layer and the insulation
layer is like 1 meter 3 meters and 1
meter so in the ratio of 1 is to 3 is to
1 so we present that and as student can
see for the normal thermal conductivity
of a conductivity values of this layers
you can see the temperature increase
across the insulation layers is more
whereas the temperature increase across
the brick layer is less it is kind of
not that intuitive that you have a very
thick brick layer but still the
temperature increase across this brick
layer is minimal so a student can get a
perspective of how this parameters
affect the real-life design of walls
yeah yeah it's a steady-state solution
we are presenting here yeah yeah and
student has left for instance if a
student wants to use a different
insulation layer which might have a
different conductivity value so let's
change it to 0.3 one and then you can
say at steady-state how the temperature
increase takes place across various
layers so they can dig in tweak in
different insulation values and they can
plan how the wall should be modeled
subsequently we then introduce a bit
more complexity to a simple model by
adding a convection element at the
boundaries and then we present them how
the temperature how the temperature
distribution takes place here I must
admit we have taken a constant boundary
thickness of 10 centimeter but it will
change in the in real life based on the
fluid velocity across the walls so here
we add more complexity and we show that
there is a nonlinear behavior at the at
the at the boundaries so in this way we
start adding more complexity to the
model similar to what I discussed in
excise 1 of designing a wall in the
subsequent exercise we design of window
side wall and other room components such
as floors so just flows roof M people so
these are all pre made by us we just
explain how we did that so a student can
replicate if they want to and then we
combine all the simple models which we
created before into a room model so this
is a system model model of a room where
we have it's a model of a single room
where we have four layers floor roof and
people to represent the heat gain inside
the room and we are considering the
thermal mass inside the room as a heat
capacitor so
for a fixed ambient temperature we see
how the for a fixed outside temperature
of for say minus 10 degree centigrade we
show that if the initial temperature is
20 degree centigrade without any
radiator how the temperature inside the
room gets stabilized after a certain
interval of time so this is without any
without a radiator because inside a room
10 degree centigrade it's not at all
suitable for habitation so then we in
the excise for modeling the radiators we
model the realtor using electric
electric so electrically data or as a
water like it is a water radiator so we
have those two architectures but I will
not go that in this presentation today
let me show you the most important part
of this model in which we take we use
Wolfram Alpha to get the temperature
data of one winter day in Rome so you
can see it's a nine hour data starting
and the minimum temperature is six and
maximum goes to 11 so this is how a
temperature profile of one day in Rome
looks like we then feed this model feed
this temperature data to our room model
and you can see how the room behave
other thermal conditions inside inside
the room behave here the green line
shows also temperature the blue line is
the reference temperature which is which
our user sets and the orange line shows
the temperature fluctuations inside the
room and the blue line here shows the
on-off cycle of the radiator so you
might try to relate with the other
on/off cycle of the radiator with this
temperature fluctuations inside the room
so this is for a nine hour period we
also for this given set of parameters we
also calculate the different energy and
power consumption in this model for
instance you can see for this
configuration we have an energy
consumption of 37 kilowatt hour
so if a student wants to see how a
simple change in setting the reference
temperature by by increasing the
reference temperature by one degree
centigrade has an effect on the model so
now you can see the energy consumption
increased 253 kilo watt or so there is
there was a change of I think around 15
kilowatt R by just increasing the
reference temperature of 1 degree
centigrade so we want students to
understand that how that choices has an
effect on the energy consumption a
student might want to also correlate
this change in energy consumption to the
carbon dioxide emission and to climate
change if they want to but we present
how they can use the equations to
understand a bigger concept so in this
so in this short presentation of the
room heating lab I showed you how we
used this philosophy of a complete
workflow going from trivial to
non-trivial model we showed I showed how
we compare scenarios and how we use
interactive materials for that next
important thing is how do we make this
adaptable to any course so this virtual
labs which I showed you are open
educational resources and by that I mean
we provide all the system model models
which we used to create this labs for
instance in the room heating lab this
are the components which he used in the
room heating lab if you're a professor
and if you want to extend this example
by introducing one more room what I
showed you was a single room model if
you want to combine two rooms and you
want to check the behavior you can use
this already pre-made components and
expand your models so you have the
ability to increase upon or to change as
your course requires second if you are a
teacher not familiar with Mathematica we
have teacher materials
on request which in which we go through
how you create manipulates using system
all in the background so if you are a
newbie to Mathematica it will help you
to create interactive contents next
important thing was we have we have an
objective to cover a wide range of
curriculum to explain how system
modeling and Mathematica can be used in
different fields not in a particular
physics or mechanics silos and for that
we develop and we are developing this
courses not by ourself but in
collaboration with professors and
teachers for instance we developed
college thermal with Professor Matthew
from Politecnico di Torino we also have
high school chemistry and high school
biology which we developed in
collaboration with professors from Lynn
shopping University where we're from
Matt cava settled and we have other
courses in the pipeline such as college
biology high school physics and various
other courses which will be released
within two or three months we are
working hard on them
next is resources we have if you want to
use this labs you can go to the system
modular library store and in that we
have three labs which are live right now
College thermal high school chemistry
and high school biology before using the
lab if you want once you go to the lab
you have examples for instance we have
room eating and refrigeration cycle
before using the lab if you want to know
what I'm going to you see in this labs
you can click on the example which will
take you to the example pages so it will
give you a brief introduction of what we
are trying to do in this lab and you
feel if it is relevant to your course or
even tweak it in a bit to make it sweet
or for your courses you can go through
this examples we also have we also
released a block I think one month back
which goes through this is a block I
wrote in collaboration with Professor
Matteo
we completely go through this lab and
explain you how this lab works and also
the experience of Professor Matthew when
he developed this labs in collaboration
with us so these are the three resources
which we had which we have for you also
we have we are creating videos where we
go through this virtual labs and explain
you how we develop this how to use this
those videos would be live in two or
three weeks after the conference so
these are the resources which we have
for you and if you if you as a professor
or enthusiast who is an expert in a
field and who wants to contribute to the
community by creating interactive
contents for students you can contact us
we will help you in developing this labs
you can send us you can meet me after
this after this conference or after this
meeting or you can drop us a mail at
virtual labs at the rate will front calm
so before finishing my presentation I
would reiterate on our key values we
want to make teaching come alive we want
this course is to be adaptable to any
course and we want to cover the whole
curriculum and with this I would like to
conclude my presentations and now I can
take any questions if you have thank you